something going toward the rim
and it comes to durant he's going to try
to win it
kevin durant hits a three-pointer and
the sonics win the ball game see if
there's any time left with the ball
going through the net
and he got it off plenty of time nope
it's over folks seattle has won it
in double overtime what a
night of basketball and it ends in
plunkett kobe bryant never should have
gave that ball up to powell default
even though he was wide open
this is for the lead kevin durant the
nba's leading scorer
with a feathery three-point jumper that
puts
the thunder on top with 13.7 to play
and that's the difference when i talk
about kobe bryant not giving up
the ball to you'll be able to see the
double team coming if it happens
there's ellington right at the
free-throw line area k.d gonna rare back
fire for three kd from graves
with 3.9 seconds remaining
in the fourth quarter
[Applause]
repeat after me thunder fans
that is one cold flooded dude
again there's ellington so kevin durant
decides to go the other way
can't use a lot of time here kd corner
three
a firing got it got him to tie
with 10.1 seconds remaining
kd for three again
and you're able to execute at a level to
get that shot
you are improving in the process of
getting better
is right on display what a terrific
screen
by collison that frees up durant who
does the rest
bringing 18 203 to their feet
in ecstasy that shot's in the air and
people here are on baited prep
and it goes through the net and an
explosion of excitement
here's lamb
knocked away by johnson durant he's
gonna pull up
for the lead and he drills it
kevin durant with 51
119 118 1.7
seconds left here in double overtime
wow you want to talk to mvp
how about this amir johnson do
everything you can he knocks the ball
away he's right up by the red
doesn't make a difference we'll see how
the thunder plays
cephalosia will throw in
[Applause]
here
[Applause]
their best started pulling up up
primarily here in the fourth quarter
when it counted
kd looking for more
memphis has had an answer all night a
quick 6-0 run now i got a piece of that
one
almost out of bounds somehow durable
after the deflection there
didn't look like he had gone out and now
you have to confirm the three-point
looked like he was behind the line here
let's see here
westbrook was not out yes clearly a
three
unbelievable are you kidding me my
goodness kareem screen and here we go
durant checked by galinari k.d gonna
rear back and win it
thunder wins thunder wins
thunder wins with a buzzer beater by
kevin durant
how about that
to get him the ball and let him win the
ball game or go into overtime and kevin
durant
got the distance or the separation that
he needed and here's durant picked up by
garcia
durant will take the three off the
rim it's good and the thunder leaded by
one and then you talk about a special
three-pointer
in the 2012-13 season this is the one
right here how about the soft touch
side out of bounds i think it was a
two-for-one opportunity they wanted to
get a quick look for durant at the top
and the iron
very kind we saw some great shooters
last night and here we go again
[Music]
kd k.d 13.5 remaining
durant brings the thunder all the way
back even
he's got 39 points
[Applause]
now and the thunder displaying
tremendously
durant singled up with haywood
he fights over the screen but sets
that screen that gives kd just enough
room to score it from three
durant scoreless until the last couple
of minutes
and now seven points
to help the thunder gain a little bit of
the ball game
and the thunder now in a tie game durant
for three for the weight he's got
it he's got it he's got it half half a
second remaining
and durant has done it again he's got it
[Applause]
can you believe it
with the rebound got some time here k.d
across the timeline
spots up and he scores he scores
40 feet away from the basket count it
they'll review it
but you know it's good wow
now what were you saying about the
three-point shooting
she is defending the inbound it's
westbrook
it's durant the smaller coal defense got
it
that's a three 32
for kevin durant two-point game quick
foul
[Applause]
the trust of west brook kevin durant
kept clapping and calling for it look
how far out
duran on the drive ibaka
back out durant for three
westbrook's pass picked off by peculiar
there's curry behind the back
they are not enjoying this in oklahoma
city
but the warriors are because i just saw
thompson on the scoreboard think about
it he's been struggling with the 10.8
that was first in the league this year
now
they have a differential of six they ran
for
it at the three and kevin durant
makes it a four-point ball game
and continuing to hurry is inserted back
in
deflected by rubio two seconds left kd
to end the half good
[Applause]
just how you draw it up did you even
doubt
that it wasn't going to go in
[Applause]
immediately so you have more time final
five seconds of the half
kd at two he's got a rise for a three
and he got it
that matter of a man's hanging on you
back to durant puts up a three it's good
and a foul
kevin durant with a chance for a
four-point play
and live it looked like the right call
kevin durant was not allowed to
[Applause]
durant way downtown bang
kevin durant drills the three-pointer
and here's the boost from the crowd as
golden state goes up
19.
[Applause]
different offensive weapons for golden
state and they are certainly an elite
defensive team
but they have made more mistakes tonight
than i've seen in a long time in a spurs
team and right on cue
fouls a three-point shoot
mono ginobili a little shaken up grabs
his right right foot after committing
james is now guarding durant
[Applause]
long three kevin durant rattles home the
three-pointer
have you kevin love you got to be up on
that screen it's a great shooter coming
off the pick and roll
force the issue and get him to pass
incredible opportunity durant for three
it's good
kevin durant from downtown and golden
state takes the lead
and they should get a two-for-one here
irving guarded by klay thompson
[Applause]
durant on the pull-up at the buzzer
kevin durant knocks down the three
they'll review it but he got it off in
time
but it has golden state in possession
two on the shot clock durant
oh he is on fire
80 71.
[Applause]
and you go by him but when you go into
him or he comes into you it's tougher
and it's going to be
a four-point play possibility the three
and the foul and a chance to make it a
single-digit game
so do the warriors have a little magic
here
i like the improvement in willie cauley
stein
jakarta sampson hits the deck and durant
hits a three
he's standing up he's got both hands
spread out like
palms to the ceiling like i can see why
dave young is so excited by some of
these young players sure
durant another one this is good too
warriors have had eight shots in a row
durant's got
31 six of seven from three you can also
see why steve could
he get one point a real small lineup and
kd is not going to get back in there and
play the
the big man back to back
kevin durant who's got 43 points
what is the record for consecutive
four-point plays
in the history of the nba
durant 21-6 and six and a three
oh man just shot right over
wrench like he wasn't even there that
was like a practice shot
for durant looks like then it's a lead
at 12 for the warriors the defending
nba champions spinning on that block
over looney who defended well but
through the
it's davis so he's hit on five
of six from the field the rack with a
deep three yes
hill making contact and durant
will go to the line shut [ __ ] down to
seven
[Applause]
gotta go durant over
[Applause]
[Applause]
kevin durant way outside delivers
kevin durant from downtown it's a
six-point game
that's the same spot where he hit it in
game three last year
[Applause]
billy owens at his best at his best yes
oh yes
final seconds hits from near midcourt
of three for the race
time runs out and that is the
end of the third quarter kevin durant
has straight steve percy's play on as
durant looked over at the bench
here's the red ten seconds
goes to the corner of the shooter hits
to tie it up
kevin murray dribbling into the corner
to look for the tying shot and he does
just
that timeout toronto 8.6
remaining in regulation
steph to tie the game
batter back out durant to tie it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
durant long three count it and the foul
kevin durant with a chance for a
four-point play
from several feet beyond the arc
and looks down at the other end of the
floor to his gm bob myers
shakes his head